[music]
>> So really appreciate this event and
really great to meet everyone. I'm
Steve, founder CEO of LiveAction.
And today my topic is building the
continuous learning system for physical
AI.
Yeah, a little bit very quick
introduction of myself. I'm the founder
CEO of LiveAction.
And
so basically previously I was mainly
based in Silicon Valley. So I was at
Cruise
managing Cruise
autonomous driving simulation.
And after that I was at Nvidia.
So I was the head of Nvidia's simulation
department.
So what is LiveAction?
LiveAction is basically the continuous
learning infrastructure for physical AI.
So what we specialize in is basically
the real to sim to real technology. That
we are working on basically three major
products.
The first one is Ego Suite which is the
human egocentric video.
For robotics training
which right now is mainly for
pre-training stage.
And for this product we are very proud
that we successfully supported Ego Scale
which is Nvidia's egocentric
which is Nvidia's model based on
egocentric data.
The second one is Robo Finals. So Robo
Finals is the most scalable high quality
simulation evaluation benchmark
for robotics frontier models.
Then we also have the third product
which is Robo Stack.
So Robo Stack is basically the
deployment stack
um
for robotics foundation models. So, now
you see we have data,
uh we have evaluation, and also we have
deployment.
We are also very proud that uh we are
supporting, you know, almost all the, I
would say, important players in this
space. Uh that includes all the robotics
foundation model world model
companies, right? OpenAI, DeepMind, uh
Nvidia Gear Group.
Um
Also, at the same time, we are
supporting, you know,
almost all the
most advanced uh humanoid companies.
That includes Figure, uh that includes
Sanctuary, uh AG Bot, 1X, all of them.
We are also very proud that uh we are
supporting a lot of great industrial
companies
who are working on embodied AI, working
on robotics right now, right? For
example, Samsung, uh BYD.
Uh
like a lot of OEMs, um and also a lot of
hospitals.
So, uh we were being mentioned uh by
Jensen in his GTC keynote
for almost all the past three or four
keynotes.
And uh one thing which is very special
and also proud of me is uh
we are only a 3-year-old company. We are
only 3-year-old. We were founded back in
2023.
And in this Q1
uh we got sales order of 100 million US
dollar
uh for just Q1.
Right? So, this is a This is going to be
a very special year for us. This is
going to be a very special year for us.
And also, by the way, uh we are hosting
a party tomorrow evening. Uh you know,
to celebrate.
So, really uh invite everyone to come to
the party.
So, I just want to tell us uh tell
everyone why it happened, right? Uh why,
you know, uh we got this opportunity, uh
we got a lot of sales number. So, what
is the logic? What is the reason behind
it?
So, I think the logic behind it is
physical AI requires much more data
than self-driving, than large language
models.
And actually, in my prediction, physical
AI would require 1,000 times more data
than self-driving and large language
model. Why?
Uh because for large language model, for
self-driving,
uh the pre-training data site is for
free, right? For self-driving, if you
have OEM like Tesla, you have all the
cars driving on the road,
uh the drivers are collecting data for
you for free, right? So, you get all the
data for pre-training state for free.
For large language models,
basically, the internet is your
pre-training site, and you can download
the internet at almost no cost,
right? So, basically, pre-training is
for free
for self-driving and also for large
language model. But for robotics,
there's no pre-training site. We have to
build a pre-training site,
right?
The second thing there is for
self-driving, you know, there's not that
much about physical interaction.
It's almost all of them are
non-physical. For example, like
prediction,
uh vision stuff, right? Uh because you
don't want to hit the other car or the
pedestrians on the road. And actually,
the only physical interaction
for the car
uh
with the environment is actually the
vehicle dynamics,
right? The car with the ground.
But for robotics, everything is
physical, right? So, as we human
interacting with everything with our
with our hand, the robot needs to
interact everything with their hand or
with their gripper.
Right? So, it increase a lot of the
degree of freedom, the difficulties.
Right?
The third thing is for evaluations.
Uh for self-driving and also for large
language models, you get
real-world feedback from the real users
all the time, right? For Tesla, you get
real feedback from millions of drivers.
Uh for uh ChatGPT, you get real feedback
from all the users, right? Millions of
users. But actually
for robotics, there's no real uh
real-world feedback because we don't
have a fleet. We don't have a fleet yet,
right? The largest amount we have ever
shipped till now is around 30,000
robots. So, that's it. There are only
30,000 robots.
So, the only thing we need to leverage
actually is simulation.
So, here is basically
the data pyramid, right? The data
pyramid for robotics, right? And as I
mentioned, the real robot data is only a
very tiny bit.
But if you
uh multiply a thousand by 1 million,
which is the largest uh real-world
physical AI data fleet by Tesla, then
that's 1 billion. You actually would
need 1 billion data generators. But for
the real robot, right now you only have
30,000.
And if you put a maximum on it, say 1
million, it's still 0.1%
of all the data we would ever need,
right? So, that would mean that 99.9% of
data should be not robotics related.
Right? So, where should we get the data?
We can get the data from human.
Human egocentric data, right? Human
videos.
Or we can also get the data from
simulation.
And this is also one of our learning by
building Light Wheel, you know, at the
first we were like everyone, data is
fuel, right? We are just providing the
fuel, the gas for AI. But the more I'm
working on it, the more I just learned
data is not fuel. And actually it's
uh the opposite of fuel.
So, what is fuel? Uh fuel is something
that uh there is a standard. Once you
hit a standard, then that's it, right?
You need to reduce your price, you need
to work on the competition, right? You
need to increase your supply.
But actually data is more like learning,
right? So, as we human being, we are
always looking for more knowledge, more
insights
uh from better people,
right? Uh we are always willing to pay
more for the knowledge we get from uh
for the insights we get, right?
Uh
uh a lunch with Warren Buffett would
cost you 5 million US dollar, right? And
even for Warren Buffett, when he's at
his 90s,
he's still uh reading a lot of books.
And probably more books than us reading
every day,
right? So, that is really data for AI,
right? So, then if you look at, you
know, the stage of data, right? The very
first stage is uh
uh uh for the credit of Fei-Fei, right?
Uh the static data set by ImageNet,
right? It is the first time
um we human ever found out data data set
at a large scale is very important for
AI.
The second stage, also I would say I
want to give credit to Scale AI, which
is doing a really great job of building
the data factory, right? Data
operations, right? Um they are
operating, you know,
uh hundred of thousands of people, if
not more, right? Generating data at all
time and also increasing their quality.
Right? But, I think we also need a third
stage, uh which is what Level is
building right now, which is the
continuous learning stage, right? Just
like we human, um we are constantly
learning from everyone. We are
constantly getting feedback from
everyone.
Um
so does robotics. So, that's the
continuous learning loop that we are
building.
And I would argue that for physical AI,
as I just did a calculation, uh 1
million multiplied by 1,000, physical AI
would require 1 billion continuous
learning loops.
And actually, through history, through
history, to today,
the world's largest continuous learning
loop for physical AI is
Tesla's FSD fleet, right? Which is a
million cars, right? A million cars is
pretty amazing for Tesla to collect all
the data from the drivers, right? Also,
um form of human data, but
it is only enough for Tesla, for their
FSD, but it is not enough for physical
AI,
uh for human noise.
And what we would need is a billion
a billion continuous learning loops.
So, if we really compare human versus
robots, right? So, I think their
learning should be very, very similar,
right? We, as human, what we are doing
every day for learning? We are actually
getting demonstrations from human,
right? As we were kids, right? I have a
kid who is 2 and 1/2 year old. I'm
giving him human demonstrations every
day,
right? Um
so so, basically, watching other people
to get human demonstrations, right? So,
that's the same as robots getting human
demonstrations from data, from
egocentric data. All right.
Uh we as human, we are also constantly
getting feedback, right? We are getting
feedback when we are young taking exams.
We are getting feedback uh from our
teachers. We are getting feedback uh
from our managers. We are getting
feedback from our peers.
We are getting feedback from our family,
and also we are getting feedback from
our reflections, from ourselves.
All right? Same for the robots. Robots
should also get feedback. That is
evaluations, right? They should get
constant evaluations
for where they are.
There is also the third thing,
which is we as human, right? Um
I will say that after uh we graduate,
after we get into a real job, it is
actually the start of our learning,
right? We start to learn more on our
job, right? It's not like after we
graduate from college, after we graduate
from PhD, we stop learning. It's
actually the opposite. We start to learn
more, right? Same should be for the
robots. After the robot is deployed in
the real factory, in the real scene, it
should collect more data, more feedback
to help with its learning.
Right? So in this way,
the real learning continuous learning
system for physical AI should be based
on three major things: the data,
the evaluation, and also deployment.
Those three are the most important
things for robotics to learn.
Right? But then there are there comes a
problem, there comes a challenge.
How can we solve
the scaling bottleneck of physical AI
evaluations, right? For data, we can
leverage human egocentric video to
learn, right? There are billions of
human in the world.
But how can we scale evaluations?
There is no way we can scale it as GPT
or as Tesla FSD
by the real fleets
by getting the real feedback from the
the real users.
The only way for us to scale evaluation
is through simulation.
Right? Because it it is deterministic,
it is reproducible,
it can be physically accurate.
Right? The most important thing is it is
diverse and scalable.
Right? So, I would argue that simulation
is the only scalable path for physical
evaluations.
Now, this comes the real product of Live
View, right? This is the Live View's
continuous learning infrastructure,
right? For the data side, we are
providing human demonstrations by Ego
Suite, the world's
most scalable, but at at the same time
highest quality
human egocentric video
for robotics foundation models.
Right? The second thing is evaluations,
which needs to be based off simulation
evaluations, not real evaluations.
Then I introduce RoboFinals, which is
the world's most scalable and high
quality
simulation benchmark for robotics.
Then there is RoboStack
to enable everyone to deploy faster and
also collect feedback
in deployments,
right? Back to the continuous learning
loop. The three products are the
critical products for Live View
uh
to provide a continuous learning
service.
But also I want to introduce the thing
in the center, right? Because
now we have the real data, we have the
simulation benchmark, we also need to
have the real deployment. That would
mean that we need to have a scalable
infrastructure deep down that's
supporting real to sim to real, right?
Um from the real egocentric data uh to
uh uh to make all those things into
simulation evaluation benchmarks. And
also leverage our simulation evaluation
benchmark to turn sim to real of the
model into real deployment. So, the real
to sim to real infrastructure is
actually the most critical
infrastructure deep down uh for Live
View.
And Sim Factory is actually in the front
and center, which is the real to sim
infrastructure for physical AI. It has
three major things, right? The first
thing is the solver, right? We need to
have the best solver in the world,
right? To enable us to simulate the most
accurate physics.
But solver is not enough. You actually
have to be able to collect real physics
from the real world and put them into
simulation. So, the capability of
marrying real physics in the front from
the world scalably is very important.
So, that's our second
critical thing.
The third thing is after you have the
real physics, you have the solver, you
need to have a scalable way to produce
sim ready assets.
Right? So, this is just one of our
factory to turn real physical
measurement into simulation.
And uh uh we are basically uh building
all the different type of sim ready
assets, right? Leveraging, you know, the
best solvers we have built and also the
solvers that we contributed to Newton uh
in order to make all the uh phy- uh
physical parameters correct,
right? But most importantly, uh Uh, we
have RoboFinals, uh uh, which from our
side, you know, we are collaborating
with all the partners, our ecosystem
partners,
uh, right? To really, you know, deploy
scalable and high-quality simulation
benchmarks.
And this benchmark is built upon
ISAAC Arena, uh, which is co-developed
by Live View and also NVIDIA.
So, this is a simulation, uh, benchmark
infrastructure that we have built,
collaboratively built, together with
NVIDIA.
And with this stack, with the Robo
stack,
we are actually supporting, you know,
the Groot 1.7
um, Sim2Real deployment feature set for
industrial factories.
Right? So, this is the best, I would
say, example of for us to build out this
continuous learning loop, right? Uh,
from the egocentric data to the Robo
Final, which is the evaluations, and
then to the Robo stack, which is a
deployment stack, uh, to help, uh, the,
um,
uh, the robotic foundation model, to
help the robotics partners,
uh, to deploy the robots into the real
scene.
And I would say that the physical AI
would require an open learning
ecosystem.
Right? Um, for example, for
um, the solvers, it is very critical,
right? And it's very difficult for one
party to build it alone and make it
closed source.
Uh, we are very proud that we were
invited by NVIDIA,
uh, by DeepMind, and also by Disney
Research, and also joined with TRI to
join the Newton Technical Steering
Committee. So, Newton is, I would say,
the best, the most accurate, scalable,
GPU accelerated
uh physics solver in the world, right?
Which is also open sourced, right? We
are very proud that we are contributing
to Newton, right? Helping it to scale,
helping it to add on more solvers,
helping it to have SimReady asset
standards.
Helping it to put up to be put into Robo
Finals, to be put into Robo stack, uh to
accelerate the full life cycle of
continuous learning.
And that's not only it. We are also
scaling our open human data collection
platform, right? Uh basically, we have
uh we are uh we have our own high-site,
but also we are collaborating with all
the high-site partners, you know, the
sensor partners, the gloves,
um uh
at the compute stack, right? Uh what we
are looking for is we want to build a
platform, an open platform, open
standard,
uh to scale to 1 billion data collectors
worldwide. And we feel that there is no
way we can build it alone, right? So, we
want to collaborate with with everyone,
right? And uh we recently uh
we formed strategic partnership with
Pico, with Manus, with Vuzzi, and with
many more. And we are co-designing the
next generation human data collection
platform. I'm very proud of that. And
this is just the beginning. We are very
open and eager to collaborate with uh to
collaborate with all of you uh to
integrate your uh technology, sensor,
um
hardware, compute,
models into this platform.
And uh the platform should provide three
major things there, you know. We want to
have, you know,
the evaluation guided the data loops,
which that's our specialty. We have Robo
Finns, the most scalable simulation
evaluation benchmark.
We also want to unify
the data standards.
Because we are the largest provider of
egocentric data in the world, we want to
uh provide our standard for everyone to
leverage.
But also the most important thing is we
want to collaborate all the model
partners
to uh to work on the best recipe for
data and model together. Right? This is
going to be very, very critical for all
of us uh to advance uh in human ways
uh in frontier models.
So, in the end, I just want to say
really appreciate your time and really
happy to be here and uh
let's
together build the continuous learning
system for physical AI. Thank you.